-Lil Rel,
welcome back to the show.
It's great to see you.
And I want to say
congratulations.
I met backstage
your beautiful fiancée.
-Yeah.
-You are engaged.
-I'm engaged.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You are engaged.
I want to hear all about it.
Was it special?
Did you cry?
Where did you do it?
Did you go on one knee?
-Well, let's say this,
first of all,
since I've been engaged, she's
been on like 15 to 20 brunches.
People take her out
to eat and dinner.
Ain't nobody did nothing for me.
[ Laughter ]
-I'll call you next week.
We'll figure something out.
-No, I got one call, he's like,
"You sure?"
And he hung up.
And that was it.
[ Laughter ]
-Where did you do it?
-So look, first of all,
it was a kind of
last-minute decision.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
You didn't plan on doing this?
-I didn't plan it at all.
I was so -- we --
I never told this side
of the story before.
So, y'all getting it for real.
So, there's a Chinese buffet
we like to go to.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a disaster.
This is a complete disaster.
If she comes storming out here,
I'm letting you --
you're on your own.
-On Saturdays, we -- I like --
so, I go to Chinese buffets
all over the country
for no reason.
I love --
-All you can eat buffet.
-Chicken on a stick,
it's got -- the salt
and pepper shrimp with the --
and then they got
a hibachi grill sometimes.
-Alright, let's get
to the engagement.
The engagement story.
[ Laughter ]
You got engaged.
-I got so happy, like,
"Oh, yeah."
I mean, the ice cream.
[ Laughter ]
And that weird
chocolate thing that nobody --
it never cuts off
when it's dripping chocolate.
[ Laughter ]
No, so, look, we decided to go
to the mall after that
because we were shopping to go
to a wedding the next day.
-Okay.
-And this is a true story.
I walked past the Tiffany store
because she was in another store
and I was on the other side
of the mall.
And I'm like, "Is it time?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Right.
And so, I walked in the store.
I said, "What's up, playboy?"
The guy was like, "What?"
First of all, he wasn't used
to somebody calling him playboy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"What's up, playboy?"
-"What's up, playboy?"
-But you see those
beautiful rings.
-I see -- I picked three.
It was three I picked.
I said, "Let me look.
Can I see your
engagement rings?"
He's like, "Alright."
And he probably thought
I was like window shopping.
And I was like,
"No, give me that one."
He's like, "What?"
"Give me that one."
I got to get an outfit,
you know what I mean,
for this wedding tomorrow.
So I picked the ring out,
I paid for it.
And he was like, "Yo, this is
the fastest --"
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "Dude,
there's a Chinese buffet
I got to get to.
I got things to do.
Hurry this up, man."
So, yeah, this is the fastest
sale he's ever got, right?
-That's what it was.
I need to get home after
having a Chinese buffet.
-I got to go to the buffet, man.
-I got to get home because...
-Yes, you got things to do.
-It's ice cream,
chicken on the stick.
It was a lot of mixtures.
-Chocolate fondue.
-I know, so I had to get home.
-Yes.
-Alright.
Anyway, so I get the ring
and it's in the Tiffany's bag
and I'm like, "Oh, man,
I can't let her see that
I went to the Tiffany store,"
so I'm like,
"Do you got like a plain bag?"
He was excited.
Like, "Ha, do we."
Like, I guess people
do like surprise engagements
and stuff all the time.
-You can't walk back out and
go, "What are you doing, honey?"
"I just went to Tiffany
and got myself something."
-Yeah, bought me a bracelet and
she's like, "No, you didn't."
-Yeah, exactly.
-And so I get the ring,
I get in the car
and I just leave her at the
mall, which is even crazy.
She's like, "Yo, where you at?"
"Oh, uh, I'll call you an Uber."
And no.
-Come on,
that's not true at all.
"I'll call you an Uber."
Yeah.
-So look,
I ended up getting in the car
and I call her dad,
who was in Mississippi.
That's her dad, to get his
blessing and let him know,
which is, you know, you call
an old black man in Mississippi.
That conversation can go --
I was literally -- I said,
"Look, I want to ask your
daughter's hand in marriage.
I just wanted your blessing."
He's, "Oh, that's cool.
But you know, me and Willy
fishing, so, you know."
[ Laughter ]
It was such a long conversation
about nothing.
He's like, "What were we talking
about again?" The blessing!
-I need your blessing.
I need your blessing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And so, you know,
I get his blessing.
I call her daughters
and I call my kids
to let them know
what I was doing.
And they was like, "Where
are you going to do it at?"
I said, "Well, I'm taking her
to see Beyoncé on Monday.
I'll do it at
the Beyoncé concert."
-Wow.
-And when I decided to do that,
I called Miss Tina,
who I love to death,
which is Beyoncé's mom.
Miss Tina Knowles.
-Yeah.
-She's so amazing.
-How do you know --
-How did I meet Miss --
It's a -- So we --
It's a crazy story.
[ Laughter ]
So the first time
I ever saw "Black Panther"
was before it came out.
And so this thing about --
I thought I was going
to a regular screening.
I thought it was
like a --
a special screening,
but like a regular LA,
like Hollywood screening
with like a bunch
of people there.
And I show up and it's like,
wait a minute,
this is like --
this is exclusive.
And I didn't really know.
I didn't really know
who was coming for real.
And then, like,
so I invited my friend,
Hannibal Buress,
who's staying in the Airbnb
down the street.
So I was like, "Hey, man, look,
if you want to come through,
come through."
That's before I knew it was like
an exclusive situation.
[ Laughter ]
It was very exclusive.
So Jerrod Carmichael
was there, DJ Khaled was there.
And then I see, like,
you know, when Beyoncé,
Jay-Z and Miss Tina
all walk in together,
they like walk in a triangle.
It's kind of...
[ Laughter ]
Like with security and then it's
them in the triangle thing.
And they walk in, the wind
blowing and I'm like,
"Oh, this is --"
[ Laughter ]
-The wind just blows.
-Just blowing.
-Yeah, yeah yeah.
-It's a theater. How?
Where the fans at?
Couldn't see the fans.
-That's the Beyoncé effect.
[ Laughter ]
-So they walk in with security
I'm like, wait a minute.
Is this -- Is this
an exclusive-exclusive thing?
And I tried to hurry up and text
Hannibal like,
"Hey, man, I don't..."
-Yeah, be cool.
-"I don't know if --"
Before I could do that,
somebody was knocking
on the window.
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "Hey,
the screening is canceled, dude.
-Like bing boom boom, "Yo, Rel!"
They yell, "Who invited --
Who invited Hannibal Buress?"
I was like, "I did."
-That's so funny, man.
And so, yeah, I sit next
to Miss Tina during the movie
and we was talking like
throughout the movie
the whole time.
And man, she was so cool.
And after we watched the movie
and everybody
walked out the theater,
she left her phone there.
And so I grabbed the phone
and I gave it to Jay,
and I'm like, "Jay,
Miss Tina left her phone."
He's like, "Yeah,
she always do that."
I'm like, "Oh, alright."
And so I give him the phone
and maybe like a couple of days
later after that,
a good friend of ours,
Robi Reed,
who's a legendary
casting director,
hit me up and was like,
"Miss Tina
wants you to host her gala."
And I guess, like, she ended up,
like, looking up all my stuff
after we met
and just thought I was cool.
And from that point on,
she's been
like one of my second moms,
and I appreciate her so much.
-No way.
-Yeah, she's a sweetheart.
-That's a great story.
-Yeah.
-So you call up...
-I call up Miss Tina
because I'm like --
And it wasn't --
I already bought the ticket,
so I wasn't asking for tickets.
Okay, let's get that
out of the way.
-You're going to see Beyoncé.
-Going to see Beyoncé.
It was her birthday gift.
She wanted to see Beyoncé.
That's what I got her
for her birthday.
And it was crazy because
it was a last-minute gift.
And I remember I was on the
phone with my other homeboy
and we both trying to
get tickets.
"Rel, your money different.
So we ain't going."
And so we look at --
-The money's different.
-I'm gonna just go take her
to see, I don't know,
Earth, Wind & Fire or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Fire couldn't make it.
I'm just going to see
Earth and Wind.
I'll go see Earth, Wind & Fire.
-Yeah. I'm gonna see
Earth and Wind.
-Earth and Wind.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't even afford Fire.
Yeah. I'm going to see Earth.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to see Earth.
-See the bongo player.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, I got
the tickets last minute,
But I called Miss Tina because I
wanted to make sure
I propose to the right song.
And it's the Renaissance
concert, so, I'm like,
"Is she even going to do
any of the slow songs?"
Because everything is, "Energy."
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Yeah, no, I got it, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, I'm like,
alright,
Miss Tina, what's the perfect
song to propose to?"
And she was like,
"Well, do it to 'Love on Top.'"
I'm like, "Oh, okay."
So, what Beyoncé does,
she stops the song
and lets the audience sing.
And so that's when
you should do it.
And I was like, alright,
that'll be perfect.
That's when I'm going to do it.
And then she was like,
"Well, I told Jay
that you were proposing.
And he suggests that we could
put it on the jumbotron
for you."
And I was like, "Whoa, whoa,
wait a minute, now, I didn't..."
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's already pressure.
You know, because you don't
think she's going to say --
I remember I was talking
to my son about this.
He's like, "Dad, do you think
she's going to say no?"
And I never thought about it.
Like, why would you say that?
-Yeah. Don't put that out there.
Don't put that out there.
-That's what my 13-year-old said
to me,
"What if she says no?"
And he was like laughing.
I'm like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
-"That's an option?
Yeah, I guess you're right."
-I never thought about that.
It's her choice.
And so, you know,
she told me "Love on Top."
And it was even funny
with the story.
She's like, "Look, Rel, I told,
you know, I told
Beyoncé what's happening.
And you know, she --"
Look, Beyoncé is a sweetheart,
first of all.
Let's say that. She's
a sweetheart and it's her show.
She's like, "Rel want
to do it today? This show?
On Monday, my birthday show?"
And it's like --
-Oh, it's her --
-It was her birthday show.
And I was like, "Yeah,"
but I didn't --
First of all, I didn't ask
for all the other stuff
that came with it.
I was just trying to --
I was just calling to ask the
song, you know what I mean?
And everybody else was like,
"Do the jumbotron."
-You don't even want
to be on the jumbotron.
-Because she was like,
"Do Rel understand
I have so much I got to do?"
I'm like, yeah, I do know
that you got like 15,000 songs.
You're doing dance
and choreography,
and I guess we're asking you
to take some time
for my proposal
in the middle
of your birthday concert.
-You're like, "Just give me
the order of the songs,
so I know when --"
-Well, that's the problem.
I didn't know the order, right?
And so --
[ Laughter ]
-So every song you're like --
-I'm literally
looking at the --
-Getting on one knee.
-They got the teleprompter.
-And now my next song.
You're like...
-No, no, let me tell you what.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Proposing. Not this song.
Not this song, not yet. No.
-"How many times you got
to tie your shoes?"
[ Laughter ]
And so look. But I'm looking
at the teleprompter,
trying to see if I can
figure out what song is next.
-That's smart.
-But this is the crazy part.
It was like,
'cause you know the concert.
There's a lot of
beautiful people there,
a lot of half nakedness. Right?
And so near the prompter
was these these beautiful
half naked women.
And my fiancée thought --
She was getting mad.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause she didn't know why
I kept looking over there.
But I was looking
at the teleprompter,
but I really was looking
at it the whole time.
It wasn't till
after the proposal.
She's like, "Oh, you lucky."
[ Laughter ]
"You're lucky
that's what that was."
I thought she was, you know.
So anyway, you know,
everybody's having a good time.
They do the "Energy" song.
Somebody get too energized and
spill they drink on me, right?
-So you get a drink
spilled on you?
-I get a drink spilled on me.
And so I'm like,
"I'm gonna go to the bathroom."
Now, I've been sitting there
for 2 1/2 hours,
waiting on "Love on Top."
As -- as soon --
As soon -- as soon --
And this is the crazy part
about the bathroom story.
After I washed off
the stuff, I said,
"I'm gonna use the bathroom."
And as soon as I started
using the bathroom --
-Okay.
-[ Vocalizing ]
I was like, "No!" Right?
[ Laughter ]
And they don't have
real bathrooms.
♪♪
That's a perfect --
So, because it was a --
You know, they had
the porta-potties.
So you imagine hearing somebody
at a lone porta-potty
yelling like, "No!"
-Yeah, yeah.
That plastic reverberating.
-And they had people clean
the porta-potty
that was all like,
"Is he okay in there?"
-Stay away from that one.
-[ Laughs ]
I don't know what's happening.
Someone's getting murdered
in that one.
Yeah. Oh, my God.
-"No!"
And, so, I'm trying to hurry up.
You know, I'm in my 40s,
so I couldn't do a stoppage.
You know what I mean?
I'm too old to do that.
[ Laughter ]
I had to --
You know what I mean?
I had to -- I had get out
of there. You know what I mean?
It's 2 1/2 hours.
-Yeah, you gotta --
You gotta follow through.
[ Laughter ]
-And, so, I start running back
to the seat.
And I get to the seats
and I literally forget --
It looked like they moved --
'cause Beyoncé kept making
all these demands.
So I'm like, "Did she tell
the crowd to change seats?
Like, where are my seats?"
-You couldn't find your seat.
-I couldn't find the seat.
I had to run back.
And by this time, they doin' --
Now they doin' the --
The crowd is singing, right?
-This is your part.
-This is my part.
And, so, I'm run out, run back,
retrace my steps like,
"Okay, it was over here,
and then I started --
That brother's eating popcorn,
and then --"
Like, you know what I mean?
And, so, I end up
finding the seat,
'cause I can see
the cameraman sweating, like,
on his earpiece like, "I don't
know where he at, man,"
you know?
And then the crowd sound like
they started getting irritated,
'cause they been singing
the a cappella for so long.
People was like,
"Baby, it's you?
You're the --
Why are we still singin' this?"
And then, at some point,
I swear to you,
Beyoncé was like...
And that's when I got
on one knee and I proposed.
And this is the thing about it.
I don't care.
Go watch any proposal videos,
especially with black women.
Every time they get proposed to,
they do this weird thing
where they walk --
they step in and walk back.
It's like they don't believe it.
It's like -- So --
I get -- I got up on one knee,
and this is
really what happened.
I did the one-knee thing,
and the first thing she did say,
"What you doing down there?"
You know?
"Why don't you get up?"
I was like, "Baby, I'm tryin'
to propose to you."
"You tryin' to do what?"
She's like, "Noooooooooo!
Aah! Aah!"
-[ Laughs ]
You got to do --
You know, they do this.
[ Laughter ]
She was, like,
cussing me out about,
"You gon' make my makeup --"
and all this other stuff.
And she said "yes."
-There you go!
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well done.
That is how you do it.
-Yes.
-She's gorgeous.
And congratulations
to you, buddy.
Gosh, that's a great story.
Can you tell me about this --
you and Tiffany Haddish on tour?
-Yes. This is my best friend.
I don't know if you know.
The very funny,
hilarious Tiffany Haddish.
-She's unbelievable.
She is hilarious.
-And, you know,
since we've been on strike,
a lot of us had to go back on
the road to make some money.
And so -- But, anyway,
I love stand-up.
That's our roots.
That's how we met.
That's how we became friends.
She was my first L.A. friend,
like, who would pick me up
from the airport, in the loudest
Geo Metro you can think of.
But I couldn't wait to hear
that Geo Metro coming.
"That's my ride!"
-That's what I was getting at.
-And -- But this is
our tour, man. We both --
-But I remember, didn't you do,
like, auditions together
and help each other out and --
-Auditions. I used to, like --
She used to let me crash
on her couch, right?
She used to have her printer
to print out her signs
for auditions on one of
those little TV tables,
so it was always shaking.
-Once the printer
starts going...
-Yeah. This was a TV table.
Like, "Why can't I eat my food?
I guess in my lap."
But, no, it's, like,
grinding with somebody like that
for so long, watching her obtain
all the success she has,
and vice versa, and we've been
friends for a very long --
That's how we met.
We met when we was doing
a stand-up series called
"Bill Bellamy's
Who's Got Jokes?" on TV One.
And I won my episode in Chicago.
She won hers in L.A.
And I'm backstage --
You know, I'm like, hype
and trying to calm down about
just winning,
and I hear somebody back
there like, "Unh-unh!
Here we go!
You so funny!
We gonna be best friends!"
I'm like, "Who are you, lady?"
And it was Tiffany.
-"We're gonna be best friends."
-"What's your number?
Anytime you in L.A. --"
-Oh, my God. That is so her.
-And that's how
we became friends.
She forced the friendship,
and that's --
-She's one of
the funniest people.
Both of you guys together,
I can't --
-This is gonna be fun.
This is two headliners for the
price of one, on tour together.
-Whoo!
That's what I'm talking about.
Go check it out right now.
Lil Rel Howery, everybody.
We're going to play a game
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.